[拍手]
[音楽]
el
yeah
[音楽]
al
[拍手]
モンテバナーに金をりなぽよみー何 t が本がやためあるわいいよ
さあ今の音楽聴いていただきましたが実はどこの国の音楽家は勝った方やいらっしゃい
ますでしょうか
今の音楽は僕の国キリバスという国の音楽なんです
僕の国と思われた方鋭いと思います
実は私は太平洋にあるキリバスという国の人間なんです
えっ切ります何バス京都バスみたいな
私は実は15歳の時に1人でキリバスにわたりその後日本人として初めて
キリバス国民となりました
この一日本生まれのキリバス国民として
今日皆さんに僕が行っている活動をご紹介したいと思います
そしてこの活動がこの東北日本北の国切ります
そしてこの地球全体が
地球全体を次の世代に持続可能な形で引き渡すための青写真づくりのきっかけになると
僕は信じています
はこれは去っキリバスというんですが私たちキリバス人のことです
私たち切ります神は実は boa が私たちキリバス人は歌と踊りと話すことが大好き
な人たちです
そして僕はキリバスの人たちを対欧州の東北人と呼んでいます
なぜかというと最初はとてもシャイな人たちなんです
でも一回仲良くなるととことん良くしてくれる人たち
一緒ですよね
そして人とコミュニティ古里を大切にする文化を持っています
そして私たちはこの文化をとても誇りに思っています
さあ簡単に僕の自己紹介をさせてください
僕はこの仙台で生まれましたそして15歳までこの仙台で育ちました
小さい時からものすごく外国特に南の島に興味のある子でした
当時はインターネットなんかなかったもんですから高南の島が出ている番組はホント
食い入るように見せたんです
それで小学校5年生の時にあるテレビ番組でキリバスが紹介されていたんです
衝撃的でした僕がイメージする南の島そっくりだったんです
そのものだったんですそしてその日からキリバスは僕の憧れの国になりました
さあちょっと大きくなって仙台の高校に入学しました
でもどうしても留学に行きたいっ
回海外に行きたいそれもせっかくなら憧れの国切り橋に行きたいと強く思うようになっ
たんですもう気持ちが抑えられなくなった抑えられなくなってしまいました
高校1年生の夏休みです
それから本当にラッキーなことにいろんなご縁に恵まれてもうあれよあれよとキリバス
の手刀
たら側にある高等学校に編入が決まってしまったんです
そして高校1年生の冬僕はここ浩一先生を中退して忘れもしません1993年の1月に
一人でキリバスに迎えました
そして今僕は41歳になりました
2011年の東日本大震災をきっかけに今キリバス人として地元仙台に再移住しました
そして各地の学校や今日のようなイベントでキリバスや地球温暖化の話をさせて
いただいています
さあここで僕と一緒に皆さん是非キリバスにちょっと行ってみましょう
よく聞かれるスキルますどうやって行くんですかもちろん飛行機で行きます
で日本から3日4日もあれば着きます
キリバスは1979年の7月12日にイギリスから独立した中央チュウオウ太平洋に
ある国です
第二次大戦中日本軍の占領というのを経験しています
そして日米両軍の激しい戦いが交わされた国でもあります
人工だいたい11万人です
中央太平洋の東西5千キロに33の島が散らばっていますそして1999年まで北半球
南半球
東阪急西半球すべての阪急にまたがっていた唯一の国なんです
そして2000年には世界で一番最初に朝日を迎える国となりました
世界で一番最初に21世紀を迎えた国なんです
さあ11万人しかいない小さな国なんですが大国なんです
海洋大国なんです
陸地面積は8101平方キロと仙台市よりちょっと大きいぐらいなんですが
経済吸う息 e z が3505万平方キロもあるんです
インドの陸地面積よりも大きいんです
そしてここに特に注目してほしいですが陸地面積と eez の比率です
1たい4377
とにかく大きな海にお渡した大きな実を私たちは持っています
ですので私たちは海と一緒に生きているんです
海に生かされているんです
僕はキリバスという国がたことん大好きになりました
そして心からこのキリバスという国に貢献したいなと思うようになりました
そこで23歳の時にキリバスに帰化しました
キリバス国籍となりました日本人としては第一号です
自分で会社を立ち上げてその他にもフロント本当にラッキーなことにいろいろな役職を
させていただきました
そしておそらく僕世界で一人だけだと思うんですが
日本語とキリバスもの同時通訳ができます
はこれがキリバスの美しい島々の一つです
とにこの美しい島々
美しい人々
このし私たちこの美しい島々を故郷よと呼べることなんて幸運なんでしょうか
そしてこの幸運を幸せを皆さんと分かち合いたいなと思うんです
でも
2000年あたりから
地球温暖化と飛行変動の影響をものすごく
受けるようになりました
島のお年寄りに聞いてもこんなこと今まで経験したことがなかったって言います
この写真まあ何気ない南の島のある日の写真に見えますが実はものすごく残酷な写真な
んです
何が残酷か
スライドに出ている赤い線のところまで本来土地があったんです
ところが地球温暖化によって海面が上昇して土地が削られるように行った
そう結果こうやったヤシの木が露出しましたそして次の道小ではこのヤシの木が倒れて
しまいました
国中こういう崇敬今当たり前の光景になってしまっているんです
海岸線の木がたくさん倒れているんです
キリバスの島々の平均の海抜は実は1.5メートルから2メートルしかないんです1つ
の島を除いて
首都たらはは東西40キロありますが幅は350メートルしかないんです
ひき間違いじゃないですよ皆さん350メートルです右見ても左見ても海なんです
400m リレーしたらアンカーの人は最後50m 泳がないといけない
そういうスタよこそ長い狭い島なのでちょっとした天候や海の変化にものすごく脆弱な
んです
本来キリバスの島々は穏やかな赤道性の気候でした一年の間で雨季と乾季が非常に
しっかりしていました
ところが
雨がものすごく furutoshi と降らない年になってきたんです
いままで経験したことがないような嵐がたくさん来るようになったんです
こういう嵐が来ると怖いんです
逃げるところがないんですた課題がないんです
海岸線から離れようって走って行ったら今度は反対側の階段性についてしまう
なので怖いんですとにかく
世界銀行は最悪のシナリオによるさ世界銀行が調べた最悪のシナリオにある良い夜と
2050年
た首都のたらはの8割は
海に沈むだろうと予測しています
この首都たらはにはキリバスの人口の半分以上住んでいます
そしてアバヤん桃のて部になこと言う村腕は既に
村の移住が強いられてしまいました海水が入ってきたためです
これがその村です
この写真の真ん中に爪楊枝みたいに刺さっているのはヤシの木です海水が入ってきた
ためかれてしまいました
そして根元にはマングローブの種がどこからからかたどり着いて入るようになってき
ました
これが地球温暖化なんです
これが私たちの島々すべての村で起こってしまうんじゃないか怖いんです
私たちの故郷がこうなってしまわないか怖いんです
そして地球温暖化気候変動というのは海面が上昇して島が削られてしまう島がなくなっ
てしまうという問題だけではないんです
まず飲み水の問題がありますキリバスは海抜1.5m から2名
2m の島々なので山がないんです
山がないので変わらないんです
じゃあ飲み水通しているか
雨水を直接貯めるか雨が地面に浸透してわずかな地下水を作る
ところが海水が入ってくるようになって地下水がしょっぱくなっています
私たちおそらくキリバス人は世界で一番しょっぱい水を飲んでいるでしょう
そして悲しいことにそこのしょっぱい水を飲んだせいでなくなってしまう赤ちゃんたち
もいるんです
そしてもう一つ
海の生態系が地球温暖化によって変わっています海の温度が上がる3性能道がある
上るそれによって魚が今まで食べることができた魚が食べられなくなっている
取れなくなっている私たちキリバスの人たちはタンパク質をほぼほぼ海からとってい
ます
ですのでこれはもう食糧問題なんです
そして最悪の最悪
故郷を離れるという選択を迫られる
ヒキナンです
この
キリバスにとって一大事です地球規模のこんな大きなこと
僕は1キリバス國人として何が出来るかとても悩みました
でも一つ気がついたんです
それはやれることできることをするしかない
こんな新刊こんな簡単なことなのですがそれに気がついたんです
k バスの文化では人がものすごく大切なんです
人と話すことが大切なんです
なので僕はこの世界で2番目に低い温室効果ガスを排出しているのに一番最初に地球
温暖化の影響を受けてしまう
私の国キリバスのことを一人でも多くの人に伝えることこれが僕の役割だて気がついた
んです
ちょっと普段の生活皆さん振り返ってほしいんです
地球の裏側からはるばる食卓までやってくる食べ物
毎日何百トン何千トンという二酸化炭素を吐き出しながら食卓まで行ってきます
この食べ物の方が安い
これでおかしくないですか
夜中の2時3時に雑誌や鳥の唐揚げ屋おでん買う必要ありますか
本当に必要ですか
これだけ地球温暖化がいわれているのに電気を作るためにいまだに石炭を使っている
これっておかしくないですか
いまさらと思わないでください自分のやることをこんな自分なんか力がないから何の
意味もないなんて思わないでください
ぜひ考えて行動に移してほしいんです僕は一人一人の力はものすごく大きいて信じてい
ます
なぜならばこの問題は政治でも化学の問題でもないんです
人間の問題なんです
この問題は私たち人間が引き起こしたので私たち人間が解決するしかないんです
そして僕は人間が解決できるって希望を持っています
地球温暖化は人災です
人災なので逆に言うと防ぐこともできるんです
僕はいろんなところの小学校や中学校高校でキリバスの話をするときにまず自己紹介を
します
僕は小さい時にキリバスに行きたいなんていう突拍子もない夢を持っていましたという
話をしました
そして実際行動しました強い意志を持ってその結果僕はキリバスに行くことができまし
た
人間希望を失っちゃ僕は
ダメだと思うんです
僕はこの地球温暖化という問題解決できるって
希望を持っています
東北の皆さん東日本大震災を経験しましたよね
古里を失うことの辛さ
故郷が傷つくことの心の痛み世界で一番知ってる皆さんじゃないですか
そして強い意思と行動でここまで復興されたわけです
皆さんが一番知っている
そしてが私たちキリバスの子供たちがこの先故郷がなくなってしまうかもしれないと
いう機器を今抱えてるんです
2050年
最悪の最悪のシナリオが起こって
キリバスに住めなくなってしまうという状態になったとき
この子達は何というでしょうか
この子たちはきっとこう言うでしょう
なんで私たちがこんな思いをしないといけないの
今まで何をしてたの
なんで私たちが難民にならないといけないの
こう言うでしょう
僕は先ほど申し上げたとおりこの問題解決できるという希望を持っています
なぜなら今日こうして皆さん僕の話を聞いてくださったからです
ある格言があります愛の反対とは何か
愛の反対とは憎しみでもなく
無知と無関心という言葉です
僕はみなさんの愛に期待していますこの子たちにも青写真があるんです
安全な未来を担保できない限り青写真なんか描けないんです
僕のキリバス人としての青ざしにそれはこの子たちが描く青写真を描けるような社会を
環境を作ることですそして一人でも多くの皆さんにそのかつ行動をとってもらうような
ことのお手伝いをすることです
でも僕はみなさんの愛に期待していますこの問題僕は絶対解決できると思います
最後にキリバスなもを守りでありますて治り
てライフた後も
健康と平和と繁栄が皆さんと共にあることを心から祈っています
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]